all right samantha
samantha uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally here
right here in uh what this is leslie
county yeah
and this is hell for certain road yep or
hell for certain creek i guess you call
it
what uh you grow up with both your
parents
no who who raised you my mom
her my dad got divorced when i was about
six
and he well last time i talked to him i
had just turned eight and i'm 32 and i
ain't heard from him since so you were
raised by well my
aunts my grandma
then how would you describe your
childhood it was
it was pretty good i grew up my cousins
and how far did you go to school i
graduated and i don't get to college
okay for you and then you have children
of your own
yeah how many kids you got i got one
little boy
hey are you married no no
so you're raising him on your own well
that's my mom's actually got custody of
him
because i got a medical problem
and i'm not supposed to be left by
myself really
yeah i'd take medicine for it and
what conditions you have well
i was born having seizures
and then after i had my baby
it was like he just started back and
so if you have you have a seizure then
the child is on its own and
well my mom and my grandma tried to make
sure
somebody around me all the time cause i
ain't supposed to be left by myself
and
i take medicine for it
so have you ever left this part of
kentucky
never you ever been to tennessee or
north carolina i've been to tennessee
and
i've been to i've been ohio
i got stuck in indiana one time for
about three weeks and i about took off
walking back to the house
and i've been to pennsylvania that's as
far as i've been away from home
yeah are you happy here
yeah yeah do you ever wonder what it'd
be like to live in
big city or somewhere else never
what do you i mean this is a rough way
of living you're out in the mountains
it's
you know there aren't any stores nearby
you're kind of isolated here
in the mountains what uh what are the
upsides and downsides of living in
in a deep this is a holler i guess you
would call it
well in the wintertime you can't get out
of here
if it comes a real bad snow you're
either walking or you're stuck
and they're lights they go off
well they went off a couple weeks ago i
think it stayed off
all day about half the night so they
finally come back home so no electricity
but you have running water here and you
have yeah how do you heat
um we use a
gas stove or a current heater
and you've had jobs before or no i
worked
when i was in high school my sophomore
year they put me on
my mom helped me get on some kind of
program that you go through school
and i worked at a little store on that
program all up till i graduated
and then i i worked at kmart for a
little bit until they
closed down but other than that i ain't
do you have dreams of doing something
when you're a little girl
i got a heavy devil
i write a lot
and i always wanted to send one of them
off but
i called this some kind of publishing
thing they've been showing on tv
and the guy asked me my address and i
told him he thought i was lying and
hung up on me because your address is
held for certain road
and i've been trying to get through that
but everywhere i call like that they
think i'm lying and hang up on me
so do you find people will judge you
kind of because of your accent
have you had have you had people do this
well
i used to get on these dating sites
and you know they asked your age and all
that and your location
well most of the time when i tell them i
was from kentucky automatically
they'd asked me some of the dumbest
questions there was like what
well i'm actually thought i was incest
right
i've had them ask me as my daddy my
uncle and i don't know what all
that had people ask me but and then
sometimes when i find out that i got a
child and i'm not married
i've had someone say some pretty bad
things to me about that
which around here that's why i told them
i sped everybody around this guy young
and ain't married to their daddy or
mommy
yeah and then your accent do they did
you get you know i used to go to indiana
first my willpower with my one of my
ex's we were stayed with his grandma
and a bunch of her friends come over
well i sent her saying something to him
well they started laughing
and then they come over and started
telling me oh say this say this and
every time i'd say it they start
laughing
because your accent they said you talk
funny i swear you taught funny to me ass
you talk too proper
need to well it goes both ways every one
of them don't me like it
yeah that last night from city and does
that hurt your confidence in terms of
like maybe moving to another place
no that's good i really thought about
moving nowhere
do you have any regrets about just
choosing to stay here
and uh and the life you've chosen for
yourself
now i've thought about leaving a couple
times but
would you describe yourself as happy
yeah do you ever get depressed or
anxious or angry or anything like that
yeah i got a
anxiety problem yeah
this is a it's a difficult life here
yeah
can be sometimes when you where what are
the what are the hardest parts of living
here
yeah i mean shot going to a store is
difficult right sometimes you can't
hardly get a ride
if you you buy at the pace it might take
you out here when your vehicles tore up
or
i don't hardly go anywhere and
i mean poverty is kind of every
household is struggling to survive
the way it's got it now that virus going
around you can't do nothing
yeah but typically you you survive on
how much
a year or a month
i don't know i live with my mom i don't
so between between your you get
assistance from the government no i'm
trying to sign up on my check
and i'm kind of having difficulties with
that
and raising your child's makes it even
more difficult well he draws one
oh
and your drugs are a big thing for a lot
of young people here
is that something that's you've been
involved in you've stayed away from that
no i'm not lot of my friends
i was really two good friends of mine on
camera drugs and
they died yeah
of the people you went to high school
with uh how many have stayed have stayed
here
i don't know i've been out of school so
long
yeah but you have good friends here
but amongst people your age in this
community how many are involved in drugs
do you think
i don't know
about the only people i mess with is my
family i don't
which about everybody around there's ken
and one another so
about all there is around here family
yeah everyone's related to somebody in
one way or another
what do you think of the future of this
this region
because coal mines have kind of are
fading away and
drugs have kind of taken over what do
you think the future for the younger
generation is
i'd say by the time my little boy gets
up in like high school
i'd say it's gonna be worse because some
of the stuff they coming out one night i
use
but like if you want to go you there's
no movie theaters there's no bowling
alleys
there's no shopping malls there's
nothing
well there's a couple stores in town
over in hyden but
around here the closest store around
here is on bob fork
i ain't really nowhere around here to go
to unless you go fuller riding or
yeah it's a very simple way of living
yeah there's no cell service here
there's no technology
that well we got internet but it's like
i said it goes in and out and
hit it don't pick up too good
like one day you can have it real good
and then one day it won't even come on
for you
but do you feel like you're living the
life that you wish you would live
you're happy here
no regrets
no no what would you say is the most
important lesson
you've learned in your 30 years
um
i don't know
all right well samantha thank you so
much for sharing your story
good luck with your child and
i hope you stay warm all winter it's
gonna be hard
around here when it gets cold you
it gets tough yeah
all right samantha thank you so much
you're welcome all right
you